so it's not just the United States and
Mexico it's also China that you talk
about
China is the primary source of fentanyl
in the world so fentanyl is an opioid
that leads to 70 000 plus or minus
overdose deaths in the US every year
So reading from Wikipedia called
compared with Heroin it is more potent
has higher profit margins
and because it is compact has simpler
Logistics it can be cut into or even
replaced entirely the supply of heroin
and other opiates what do you think is
important to understand about fentanyls
as a drug there was a prescription
opioid epidemic in the United States
that kind of
went down or stopped you know well you
know still out there but like the
epidemic specific around it uh kind of
petered out and there was also marijuana
legalization
happening at kind of the same time
period
which uh you know people talking about
marijuana legalization thought it was
going to hit the cartels in their
pockets and it was going to be like a
you know a death blow to these criminal
groups
well now there's a illegal pot grows in
the United States being run by cartels
in federal lands there's the legal pot
grows that are in some way shape or form
influence and or run or owned by some
camera groups that are kind of utilizing
that
the the marijuana fields in Mexico
turned into
Bobby Fields once again
the problem is that some of these lands
were leached of all the nutrients and
you know they're not as good as
something you would find somewhere in
Afghanistan so the the yield and the
quality of it wasn't as strong as it
could be
so somebody thought about the right idea
of putting fentanyl into the mix
and not only that but also figuring out
a get fentanyl into Mexico
has a giant pharmaceutical industry that
people kind of also don't kind of know
or factor into this equation which leads
into
the free ability of chemicals going in
and out of the country and legal means
of it happening right so not only the
precursors to make it but also the
chemist and the industry to create it in
Mexico as well
some clandestine factories of fentanyl
have been found in Mexico
but realistically it's not needed with
the with the ways that the ports and the
borders are down in Mexico
um
you started seeing an influx and a flood
of a fentanyl into Mexico specifically
related to infusing it into heroin
and not only using that to feed local
drug markets but send it up into the
United States which started off this
process that we're kind of going through
still are these like similar highs and
drug-wise why do you infuse I mean
probably you're not the right person to
have this biochemical discussion or how
I don't know about the biochemical
aspect of it but like speaking to guys
that do Chiba down there that's what
that's that's what they call heroin down
there it's like a nickname for it uh
having them describe uh some of the
older stinkier darker heroin they used
to get before this whole fentanyl thing
and the highs they would get and how
much they would have to take versus some
of the stuff loaded with fentanyl that
they have to
you know also there's more higher
potency yeah there's a higher potency to
it and also there's a you know more
money to be made easier to transport
yeah but then
is this how China starts becoming part
of the picture one aspect to it that
people kind of Miss is that you know
there's no Chinese cartel you know
there's no criminal Chinese organization
working unseen getting around government
oversight in China
I don't know of any any such organisms
anything that could be labeled as a
criminal organization is is uh deeply
integrated with the government so it's I
mean I've never heard of a giant
criminal Enterprise in China operating
so we have to assume then independent of
the state I would I would have to assume
that some of these things are happening
with the know-how and inaction of the
government out there
um when covet hit there was a shortage
of fentanyl on the Northern side of
Mexico specifically related to the Tina
law cartel these guys were actually
trafficking fentanyl from the U.S down
to Mexico to infuse their product
but not the new generation cartel which
operates out of the central part of
Mexico Colima area which have access to
the seaside ports
so even during the shutdown they were
getting supplied which means to me at
least refers to anybody observing it
that the supply chain was not cut
and whatever was coming out of China was
being let out of China by by whatever
official channels would be able to shut
down or stop it God I would love to know
the organizational structure the
governmental structure of China
how they enable it
because I can't imagine
at the very top there's like a portfolio
of things we're doing in one of them is
not the most right I I think it's more
in action or just the no knows how that
is happening but just like hands off
just let this FL I I don't know if I
were to understand how large
bureaucracies work it's looking the
other way yeah you are now seeing
um pill presses brought to Mexico
Industrial Level pill presses found in
clandestine Laboratories
where they're not only infusing the the
the yields that they're doing with
fentanyl but also making fake pain
medication that is flooding U.S markets
everywhere less Rarities
is that pain medication or is that
fentanyl you know who knows and that's
how you see a lot of people dying from
ODS that are supposedly taking pain
pills and that's not what they're doing
uh so the evolution right now you're
seeing is
making something
look legit as far as pain medication
that it isn't and yeah I mean fentanyl
is
everywhere they're infusing cocaine with
it I've been getting stories from the US
of people buying it through Alibaba or
just weird online sources and it coming
in different packages and just infusing
it into into whatever is out there
it is killing off a whole generation of
people
um and it comes from one place or it's
manufactured somewhere where it's being
manufactured with the precursors and the
elements and know-how that comes from
one place
are we talking about China talking about
China because Mexico seems to have
what's the world this is such a
complicated and how do you start to talk
about the drug war when more and more
and more
China is the source of the drug
is there a drug war going on with China
there's probably an economic War well
you talk about you there's another side
to China
uh most and this is something that's
come out recently a few years back I
think but basically the ways you would
move money back into Mexico after you
have a load up here is that you would
give it to a Chinese money broker they
would put into Chinese banking system
and it immediately would just disappear
from American eyes
and then another money broker in Mexico
would receive it through a money
transfer from China so China's
incredibly good amount of money
laundering
that's another aspect I mean their
banking system is invisible to the US
basically which allows which allows the
Monies to move from one point to another
so money Brokers and people moving money
for for for the groups down there are
Chinese so that's another aspect the
element of China as far as its presence